what is the future for our species you  know in fathi korea's uh previous talk  he was talking about the factors that  are involved in space exploration and  how we can study the expression of genes  and things like that in space  exploration but we've only really just  begun human space exploration we don't  really know what happens to our species  with another century or a millennium of  space exploration where our species goes  a big question is will we see this idea  of the singularity of all of us kind of  merging into our machines when our  technology advances so fast that we  basically become the machine or the  machine takes over and leaves us behind  we don't know what that looks like it  might be likely that a lot of life out  there in the universe is post biological  life that most life is artificial  intelligence  and  basically written in silicon and other  materials of metal rather than being  built in organic chemistry as we are